how do you feel about this
growing criticism now as prison inmates
in massachusetts
reportedly will be given priority in
getting the covit 19 vaccine
as outbreaks are rising the new york
times reports tens of thousands of
prisoners will receive the vaccine
before senior citizens home health aides
and medically vulnerable state residents
the head of the state's covid vaccine
advisory group said this
we used equity as a core principle in
our recommendations
we have had a lot of cases of covit in
the prisons
and we wanted to make sure those at
highest risk
were getting the vaccine first emily i
understand your temperature
is a bit above a thousand on this
well harris i just like to to paint a
landscape for viewers here so
prisons and jails are like hospitals in
that they're total institutions
there's a population that lives there
full-time and then a commuting
population that goes in and out
and social distancing really isn't
possible now
prisoners right now in this country are
four times as likely to get coveted and
twice as likely to die from it
and 93 of them will eventually be let
back into society
the correction officers execution teams
14 out of the 50 federal death row
inmates
they are all experiencing spikes also
and i think at this point it's important
to acknowledge
all of these statistics because thus far
the answer has just been orders from
judges saying well let them all out into
population but obviously that runs the
risk
of recidivism as well as the health and
safety risks of the general population
so there has to be a way to manage this
thoughtfully inside the prisons and
jails
while also maintaining inmate dignity
and constitutional compliance
and by the way the national guard is now
stepping in for those correctional
officers that have kovid they're doing
everything from you know patrolling the
outside of the grounds and
bringing in food maintaining the health
of prisoners but they are also now
doing guard duties with in ohio for
example
just one day of training so none of this
is acceptable but all of those needs to
be part of the larger conversation when
we evaluate that yes
these inmates do deserve our compassion
and the recognition
that it would behoove us to vaccinate
them
yeah my question now goes back to the
general in charge
who has admitted that he made some
mistakes lawrence in the beginning in
terms of figuring out the kinds of
numbers and places he was going to put
vaccines
look it's leadership to admit you made
it wrong
but i want to know which batch are the
politicians shots coming from now you
got another batch
and emily laid it out that was that was
amazing with all this
but my goodness when are we going to
save the seniors they have paid
such a high price in all of this what
batch i mean do we have enough
this first go round well it seems like
it's terrible planning
um on how they're gonna do but but look
to be fair
it was always gonna be this way everyone
wants to shot i mean i've been willing
to
throw my hand up and like give it to the
seniors i've had covet
you know i didn't experience any
symptoms
a lot of us young people are willing to
say look let's take care of grandma or
grandpa
but i do think to emily's point i think
that when we look at this story when it
comes to the prisoners
i think it becomes an emotional debate
because you see these people
committed a crime but you also have to
understand
that in these prison populations and
these jails
and emily laid out the numbers of that
that it they are in the custody of the
state
that means the state is responsible for
their health and if something goes wrong
expect those family members to sue the
state and honestly
by the numbers that emily just
highlighted there will be a great
lawsuit and i guarantee you
there will be a case for them to win in
court
interesting jillian i agree with with
lawrence and with emily um it's a
complicated issue but we all know
as you said harris that the top tier
priority in this country
is the elderly people who are over 65
and
if we're going to go based on the
science these are the people who are the
highest
risk there is a strong case to be made
for protecting people who are
incarcerated
because as lawrence points out the state
is responsible for them and the state
will likewise
be responsible for their debts if large
numbers of them continue to die from
covet which we've seen
not just here in this case we're
discussing but truly
nationwide it from washington dc to
california this is happening everywhere
it's
terrible i think that we can somewhere
afford by the way that one batch
a few thousand to protect these people
by the way that age the cdc put out its
chart yesterday is 75
and up for those uh highest at risk in
terms of their elder
age